foreign
hey tony how are you doing
concealers
thank you so much
good afternoon everyone welcome
uh first a few notes on travel i had a
very productive trip to southeast asia a
week or so ago
and then i'll be heading out again on
friday of this week this time to france
to turkey
to georgia israel qatar the uae and to
saudi arabia
the conversations will differ obviously
in each country many different things to
cover
but i'm sure many of them will focus on
this administration's historic efforts
to forge peace and cooperation
throughout the middle east
that leads me to my big theme today the
trump administration has had enormous
success
in marshalling coalitions of like-minded
nations for the good of america and for
the
entire world as one example just three
weeks ago
we continued our unprecedented defense
of the unborn by signing the geneva
consensus declaration
alongside 32 other nations i'm
especially proud
that we made religious freedom a top
priority in the united states foreign
policy for the first time in america's
history
our efforts are gaining momentum we're
building
they're getting a momentum that is all
their own on november 16th and 17th
poland will host the third ministerial
to advance religious freedom or belief
this virtual event on the heels of the
2018-2019 ministerials which were hosted
here in
washington the state department are the
largest human rights events ever held
here
at the state department albania morocco
taiwan
the united arab emirates and colombia
have all held follow-on events
as well and the international freedom or
belief alliance that i launched in
february of this year
now has blossomed into 31 member states
and growing
next week i'll have a very special
opportunity to participate in a virtual
alliance ministers meeting
to solidify our plans for future
accident action in the religious freedom
space
you know we're building out coalitions
too that show our values in the economic
sphere
in recent weeks under secretary keith
kroc has traveled to more than
a dozen countries to bring freedom
freedom-loving countries and companies
together in the clean network
a group that pledges to use only trusted
vendors in their 5g
networks i'm happy announced we have
almost 50 clean countries today
representing
nearly 23 nearly two-thirds of the
world's
gdp 170
telephone companies telcos have agreed
to be clean
and many of the world's leading
companies are on board it includes 27 of
30 nato allies 31 of 37 oecd members
26 of 27 eu members
and 11 of 12 of the three seas
nations under secretary keith crock is
now down in south america he's
discussing the
clean network with the government
officials and private sector leaders in
brazil
and in fact i got the news within the
last hour that the government of brazil
supports the clean network principles
and i'm confident we'll sign an mou
in the very near future i want to thank
brazil and its leadership
for doing that we're also standing
alongside our brazilian partners to
protect the environment
with the u.s brazil environmental
framework dialogue that was held earlier
today
the united states and brazil are about
real results when it comes to protecting
the environment and growing our
economies
not empty rhetoric under secretary clark
has also led the first ever japan
u.s brazil trilateral exchange which
will advance democracy's ability
to prosper together as sovereign and
independent states
talk about asia for just a minute i'm
pleased to announce that on the 20th
of this month under secretary clark will
lead our economic prosperity partnership
dialogue with taiwan
under the auspices of the american
institute of taiwan and the taipei
economic and cultural representative
office
here in the united states the dialogue
signifies that our economic relationship
with taiwan
a vibrant democracy and a reliable
partner is strong and growing will help
increase cooperation and everything from
safe and secure supply chains
to the clean and 5g security
to health security and to more
attorney to another state bomb bureau
building out coalitions of the
like-minded last week the bureau of
energy resources
under the leadership of assistant
secretary fanon
convened a virtual meeting of the energy
research governance initiative
20 countries attended working for secure
resilient diverse and well-governed
critical energy
mineral and supply chains and we're
proud to participate in the 35th annual
joint economic development group meeting
with israel later this week
the trump administration has exerted
american leadership in unprecedented
ways and multilateral institutions too
just as we helped protect the
intellectual property rights by ensuring
that the world intellectual property
organization is run by an individual who
respects property rights
last week the united states helped
ensure that the united nations stewards
its finances
responsibly i'm happy to report
that an american with 40 years of
administrative and budget experience
will be placed in the u.n system
having won a seat on the advisory
committee on administrative and
budgetary questions
doesn't sound like much but it's a big
deal this advisory body shapes the un's
regular budget
and its peacekeeping budget it's nearly
10 billion dollars a year with more than
2 billion coming from the united states
alone our diplomats made the case
to our allies and partners on why having
an american voice on this committee
for the first time in an awfully long
time is crucial to ensuring the money is
spent responsibly
i want to congratulate donna marie
american leadership also continues on
the counter-terrorism front today the
united states and nigeria are co-hosting
a virtual meeting
with members of the global coalition
focused on countering the threat of isis
and its worldwide
branches including west africa and to
supporting ongoing international efforts
throughout the region
and in the middle east just last week
the united states sanctioned foreign's
former lebanese government minister
jabron basil
under global magnitsky authorities for
his role
in corruption the lebanese people
clearly want
their corrupt political class so much of
it beholden to hezbollah
to stop ruining their country our action
shows
that american people stand with the
lebanese people as they call for their
political leaders to chart
a new direction marked by reforms
transparency and honest
governance and on iran our efforts to
protect the american people from the
regime of tehran will not cease
today the treasury department sanctioned
an international network of companies
and individuals that procured electronic
components
for a sanctioned iranian military firm
i think it's clear by now that those who
do business with iran's military and
proliferation sensitive industries
are risking the exact same punishment
in europe the united states welcomes the
eu's adoption of guidelines for third
state participation
in permanent structured cooperation
projects
opening the door to u.s participation in
eu defense initiatives will strengthen
nato eu cooperation
as well and very importantly
interoperability
we look forward to completing an
administrative arrangement with the
european defense agency to ensure broad
u.s participation
inside of pesco closer to home our
prayers are with the people of the
region
as they recover and rebuild from
hurricane adas
to horrible devastation the united
states government is proud to have
provided assistance already to our
friends in central america
we're proud to support chile colombia
ecuador
peru as these governments work together
to address illegal unregulated and
unreported fishing
we're very concerned that the chinese iu
activity this unregulated fishing took
place off the coast of ecuador as it has
elsewhere in the world
i was with the ecuador and foreign
minister he and i both agree that this
must stop
on bolivia president trump was pleased
to send a delegation headed by treasury
under secretary brett mcintosh for the
inauguration of president luis arsey
on november 8th i also spoke to the
president-elect last week to
congratulate him on his
historic victory we also congratulate
the people of saint vincent and the
grenadines on their successful election
last week and we continue to seek
similar free and fair elections in
venezuela
and in nicaragua there's also plenty of
news before i close on the human rights
front
yesterday the state department
sanctioned four senior chinese communist
party officials and hong kong police
who have undermined hong kong's promised
autonomy and crush the freedoms of its
people
we will continue to challenge actions by
the ccp and its hong kong proxies
who stifle democracy and basic freedoms
on monday in syria we unleash the fifth
tranche of the caesar act designations
on bashar assad and his regime and the
united states commends the eu for taking
similar actions to sanction individuals
responsible
for prolonging the horrific conflict
inside of syria
we will continue to coordinate with our
eu and like-minded partners to promote
accountability for the regime there
and the atrocities it has committed
against the syrian people
in geneva yesterday the united states
presented our national report on the u.s
commitment to domestic human rights
at the un universal periodic review i'm
very proud of the work we did our
remarkable
vibrant democracy provides for the
greatest freedoms and protection of
human rights anywhere in the world
the brutal regimes shouting the loudest
about our record have the most to hide
about their abysmal treatment
of their own people and with that i'm
happy to take
questions
hi uh is the state department currently
preparing to engage with the biden
transition team and if not
at what point does a delay hamper a
smooth transition or pose a risk to
national security
there will be a smooth transition to a
second trump administration
right we're ready the world is watching
what's taking place here we're going to
count all the votes
when the process is complete there'll be
electors selected there's a process the
constitution lays it out pretty clearly
the world should have every confidence
that the transition necessary to make
sure that the state department is
functional today
successful today and successful with the
president who's
in office on january 20th a minute
afternoon
will also be successful i went through a
transition on the front and i've i've
been on the other side of this
i'm very confident that we will do all
the things that are necessary to make
sure that the
the government the united states
government will continue to perform its
national security function
as we go forward do you believe there's
widespread voter fraud that the reports
that we're getting from pennsylvania
from michigan showing vote totals and
massive leads or significant leads
with 99 reporting are going to be
overturned and that the united states
failed
to conduct a fraudulent free election
rich i'm the secretary of state i'm
getting calls from all across the world
these people are watching our election
they understand that we have a legal
process they understand that this
takes time right took us 37 plus days
in an election back in 2000 conducted a
successful transition then
i'm very confident that we will count
and we must count every legal vote we
must make sure that any vote that wasn't
lawful i'll not be counted that dilutes
your vote
if it's done improperly got to get that
right when we get it right
we'll get it right we're we're we're in
good shape should foreign leaders not be
calling
president-elect
i can barely hear you ma'am i'm sorry
yeah
i want to ask you about the sanctions
against uh
in lebanon we know that we heard that
this was
on the making for some time but i want
to ask about the timing are you
uh where you are we're doing this
uh to make a new stage for the new
administration
and also i want to ask about that and
say
to uae one we expect that to be
delivered
so the second question was about the
arms sales to the united
arab emirates so we'll have significant
announcements with respect to that here
very very soon uh we we continue to
review
arms sales all all across the world
including to our important friend and
partner in the united arab emirates
uh we're confident we will uh uh we will
be able to provide them weapon systems
that will
ensure their security and do the work
that we all need to do collectively to
counter the threat
from the islamic republic of iran and
did you ask about iranian sanctions
earlier and the impact of those
no the sanctions against gibran basil in
lebanon
are you setting a new stage for the new
administration
i want to ask about the timing that's it
yeah so i'll answer that question more
broadly no the sanctions we put in place
are because they're right and proper
and will deliver good outcomes for the
people in the country in which we
sanction their leaders who are corrupt
that certainly holds true for jabron
basile right this was someone who uh was
deeply connected to a foreign terrorist
organization hezbollah
we've now sanctioned him the lebanese
people don't want to have anything to do
with that
independent nation they want a sovereign
country they don't want the political
elites that have been corrupted
through the system that was put in place
and permitted them to loot and rob their
country they want
freedom they want prosperity they want
jobs those are the things we want the
sanctions that we put in place against
uh the former minister are appropriate
and useful
towards getting us closer to that one
day the lebanese people can have what it
is they so ritually deserve
are we expecting a new sanction
christine
hi christina hi how are you good good
good
um is there any evidence that the ccp
has
interfered in the recent election or is
trying to sow chaos in the aftermath of
the
legal challenges what's the question
about russia
ccp or any uh yeah any foreign
interference yeah so i'm
gonna leave that question to the
department of homeland security and to
the justice department the folks who
deal with that
but as i think we all said uh prior to
the election
uh we did an enormous amount of work uh
to reduce the risk that they would have
the capacity
to have a significant capability to uh
to interfere
in the elections themselves and i'll
leave the details of
what they have determined so far about
that for them to announce
go ahead i'll take one more remember
hello
hi hello secretary um you said when the
process
is completed so what when are you
yeah this is the this is the third
question just just ma'am if you would
i came out here today and talked about
important foreign policy issues this is
now the third question the most
important thing that's happening in this
country right now
i'm wondering yes ma'am go ahead and ask
your question i'll give my answer what
kind of guidance are you giving to
american diplomats and how to
characterize the results of the
presidential election
and also this department frequently
sends out statements encouraging free
and fair elections abroad
yes and for the losers of those
elections to accept the results
doesn't president trump's refusal to
concede discredit those efforts
that's ridiculous and you know it's
ridiculous and you asked it because it's
ridiculous
uh look the truth you asked the question
yes when you ask the question if you if
you will permit me to answer it
um you asked a question that is
ridiculous this department cares deeply
to make sure that elections around the
world are safe and secure and free and
fair and my
officers risk their lives to ensure that
that happens they work diligently on
that
we often encounter situations where it's
not clear about a particular election we
work to uncover facts we work to do
discovery
to learn whether in fact the outcome the
decision that was made reflected the
will of the people that's our
responsibilities what we try to do along
with partners all across the world along
with
osce inspectors to make sure that those
elections we're free for we want every
one of those votes to be counted in the
same way that we have every expectation
that every vote here in the united
states
will be counted too it is totally
appropriate the united states has an
election system that
is laid out deeply in our constitution
and we're going to make sure that we get
that right
and we have we we have all of you have
and should be committed to making sure
that that happens i think every one of
you wants that same outcome you want
every vote to be counted you want to run
the process we want
uh the law to be imposed in a way that
reflects the reality of what took place
and that's what
i think we're engaged in here in the
united states and is what we work on
every place
all across the world thank you all